bonsoir année donc merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors ça
pose évidemment plein de questions cette
priorisation faut-il faire passer en
premier certains territoires pour la
vaccination ou finalement ça revient à
faire gagner l'élue qui parle le plus
fort alors c'est évidemment surtout
parce qu'il faut soit il faut arriver il
faut qu'il y ait une volée il approche
républicaine sur sur la stratégie de
vaccination est évidemment si c est lui
qui quelques porcs qui a le plus de
vaccins ou le territoire est il plus
fort qu'à l'appui de l'acte 1 alors on a
un souci sur sur la stratégie de
vaccination sur le front républicain que
cela implique par exemple
illustration en moselle où on voit qu'il
ya eu des progrès sur le front des
chiffres alors que les chiffres étaient
vraiment préoccupant le 3 février on a
priorisé ça me semble quand même être
logique égalité ou équité de la
république dans ce cas là pour le coup
ce n'est pas les élus qui ont ils
passaient pas les élus concret est plus
forte et la demande et l'augmentation
affaire incroyable du nombre de cas et
le virus qui diffuse encore plus donc
ils vont au ski être en capacité de
pouvoir s'adapter aux situations des
territoires d avoir cette capacité
d'agilité c'est ce qu'on demande depuis
le départ au qui alors cette adaptation
des territoires ça veut dire quoi qu'on
sert avant tout les endroits où le taux
d'incidence est le plus élevé où il y as
peut-être le plus de personnes âgées
comment déterminer la priorité selon
vous alors moi je suis ni médecin ni
épidémiologistes donc je m'attache à à
bien suivre les avis et les conseils des
uns des uns et les autres ne doit-on
depuis député c'est important justement
vous êtes dingues de terrain c'est ce
qui nous intéresse le plus et j'imagine
mais ce que je vais vous dire par là
c'était que healy a évidemment cette
grille de lecture qui était essentielle
à la base et puis ensuite un échange
avec les maires avec les préfets avec
les présidents tous les présidents de
conseil départemental qui permettra
ensuite de définir et de faire appel si
besoin en était en tout cas d'avoir des
suppléments de deux vaccins s'il y avait
une situation qui se dégrade et
localement donc ce que ce que j'ai tout
à l'heure
d'avoir la capacité de répondre
précisément à une urgence territoriale
ça il faut 100 il faut se rendre et
c'est cette liberté mais c'est pas parce
qu'un les luttes rire est très fort et
réclamerait à cor et à cri les vaccins
qui en face il ya pas d des chiffres
objective et et vérifiable pour autant
qu'il aura vraiment que cela une base de
chiffres autour du travail des médecins
et des épidémies
alors vous monsieur le maire d'epinay
sous sénart quelle est la situation chez
vous sur le terrain est ce que vous avez
assez de doses
les rendez-vous sont sont possibles chez
vous alors dans ma commune aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le n'est pas le cas on est
prêts nous aujourd'hui à accueillir s'il
le fallait
et si on faisait appel à nous on est en
capacité aujourd'hui d'accueillir un
vaccinodromes dans la commune dans la
collectivité qui est à côté de la mienne
il ya quillodrome et ça se passe là lors
des semaines à un peu plus compliqué que
d'autres parce que parfois les doses de
vaccin n'arrive pas telle qu'elle était
telle qu'elle était attendu parfois ça
va ça va un peu mieux donc
donc les agents de cette commune sont
obligés un petit peu de s'adapter à
cette à cette donnée donc je crois
comprendre qu'il ya une priorisation et
c'est bien normal au regard du nombre de
vaccins à la la deuxième seconde le
second de doses pour les + 75 ans mais
dans le même temps d'ici quelques jours
quelques semaines j'étais avec les
médecins de la commune au téléphone tout
à l'heure pour faire un point avec eux
sur l'arrivée de phares zeneca dans la
dans la maison médicale donc les
médecins vont avoir dans quelques jours
je n'ai pas la date exacte mais dans
quelques dans quelques jours 10/12 par
médecin par semaine dans un premier
temps puis ça va passer à 30,12 par
médecin dans un second temps et donc à
ce moment là on verra comment ça comment
dérouleront les choses alors justement
vous parlez
damien louchats des plus de 75 ans alors
ceux qui ne résident pas dans les ehpad
semble est parfois les grands oubliés en
cette première celle de vaccination dans
les régions beaucoup tentent d'obtenir
des rendez-vous en vain c'est aussi le
cas chez vous il ya beaucoup de huy pour
les plus de 24 ans et a beaucoup qui
souhaitent se faire se faire vacciner
il n'arrive pas aujourd'hui à
tenir obtenir de rendez vous donc
effectivement c'est aussi une angoisse
qui est partagé lorsque l'on sort dehors
pour parler avec les uns et les autres
c'est une angoisse qui remonte beaucoup
parce qu'il ya une vraie envie de
vouloir se faire vacciner pour une
raison assez simple c'est pour qu'une
une vie des plus normal puisque puisse
revenir et au delà de la maladie s'est
tu et d'isolement que les plus de 75 ans
vivent depuis maintenant presque un an
donc il faut bien avoir en tête ça fait
un an que les seniors de notre pays
vivent avec pas loin de leurs familles
loin de leurs proches loin de leurs
petits-enfants et ça commence et
évidemment à peser très fortement sur le
moral des prothèses des progrès qui sont
confirmés comment ça se manifeste chez
vous est ce que vos ennemis stone istres
et viennent vous voir il ya de la colère
de la tristesse vous ressentez justement
cette lourdeur vous sur sur le terrain
alors oui t'as mélange le tout vous avez
la lourdeur vous avez de la tristesse
vous avez une forme une forme d'anxiété
alors nous on a mis en place différents
différentes
me faire mon allure différente
différents dispositifs pour justement
aller à les voir aller voir les seniors
quand on recommande besoin un dispositif
qui s'appelle présents pour vous on a un
agent communal
il va voir les personnes âgées pour
prendre de leurs nouvelles pour échanger
avec eux pour savoir s'ils ont besoin de
quelque chose de particulier c'est un
dispositif qui fonctionne très bien donc
donc il ya beaucoup de travail c'est
cette pièce dispositif va s'étendre dans
les dents les semaines dans les semaines
à venir puisque ce contact avec les
seniors est évidemment absolument
essentiel est donc de savoir de ce qui
se passe dans le ce qui se passe dans la
commune qui se passe dans la
collectivité d'avoir des échanges
c'est extrêmement important pour eux
c'est extrêmement important aussi pour
nous parce que on a un vrai attachement
avec avec avec les seniors et
aujourd'hui c'est très difficile de ne
pas pouvoir passer du temps ensemble
avec quoi merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'amiens
allouche maire ps d'epinay est ce qu est
ce que je peux rajouter je profite bien
sûr de mon bordel puisqu'on a parlé des
anciens était extrêmement important je
voulais aussi avoir un mot pour les
étudiantes et les étudiants et je
voulais juste avoir cette réflexion on
parlait des anciens avec est en lien
avec le minimum vieillesse et je profite
du temps d'antenne qui met aujourd'hui
octroyés pour parler du minimum jeunesse
qui va devenir dans l'est dans les
semaines dans les mois à venir une
nécessité vitale absolue pour pour la
jeunesse de notre pays
donc l'idée c'est aussi d'avoir le
spectre le plus large dans cette
réflexion autour du pacte républicain du
socle républicain est à mon sens le
minimum jeunesse est en est un est un
soc ce qui permettra justement de
sauvegarder ce ce pacte républicain qui
aujourd'hui est en danger merci beaucoup
d'amis à l'eau chaude avoir été avec mon
direction rt france